and what was the revelation that made
made scientists and physicists think
that a quantum computer could exist it's
not obvious you know a lot of people
thought he couldn't okay
the idea that a quantum computer would
be powerful was emphasized over 30 years
ago by Richard Fineman the Caltech
physicist and it was interesting how he
came to that realization phiman was
interested in computation his whole life
ya know he had been involved during the
war in Los Alamos he was the head of the
computation group he was the guy who
fixed the little mechanical calculators
and he had a whole crew of people who
were calculating and he figured out how
to flow you know the work from one
computer to another all that kind of
stuff and as computing technology
started to evolve you know he followed
that and our in the 1970s
mmmph particle physicists like Fineman
that's my background too got really
interested in using computers to study
the properties of elementary particles
like the quarks inside a nucleus you
know we know proton isn't really a
fundamental object it's got little beans
rattling around inside but they're
quantum and gell-mann who's good at
names called them quarks yeah and now we
have we've had a theory since the 1970s
of how quarks behave and so in principle
you know everything about the theory you
can compute everything but you can't
because it's just too hard and people
started to simulate that physics with
digital computers in the 70s and there
are some things that they could
successfully compute and some things
they they couldn't because it was just
too hard the resources required you know
the memory the time
we're out of reach and so Fineman in the
early 80s said you know nature is
quantum mechanical damage what a
simulation of nature it should be
quantum mechanical yeah you should use a
quantum system to behave like another
quantum system at the time
called it a universal quantum simulator
okay and now we call it a quantum
computer and the idea caught on about
ten years later when Peter shor made the
suggestion that we could solve problems
which don't seem to have anything to do
with physics which are really things
about numbers like finding the prime
factors of a big integer and that caused
a lot of excitement in part because the
implications for cryptography are a bit
disturbing
but then physicists good physicists yeah
started to consider can we really build
this thing yeah and some concluded and
argued fairly cogently that no you
couldn't because of this difficulty that
it's so hard to isolate systems from the
environment well enough for them to
behave quantumly and so it took a few
years for that to sort out sort of at
the theoretical level in the mid-90s we
developed a theory called quantum error
correction it's about how to encode the
quantum state that you'd like to protect
in such a clever way that even if there
are some interactions with the
environment that you can't control it
still stays robust mm-hmm but at first
that was just kind of a theorist fantasy
it was a little too far ahead of the
technology but you know 20 years later
the technology is catching up so now
this idea of quantum error correction
has become something you can do in the
lab yeah and how does quantum error
correction work I've seen a bunch of
diagram so maybe this is difficult to
explain but how would you explain it
well I would explain it this way I don't
think I've seen it said the word
entanglement yet yeah well I've been
checking off all the bingo words yet
okay so let's talk about entanglement
because it's part of the answer to your
question which I'm still not done
answering what is quantum physics so
what do we mean by entanglement it's
really the characteristic way maybe the
most important way that we know in which
quantum is different from ordinary stuff
a kind of classical what does it mean
entanglement it means that you can have
a physical system which has many parts
which have interacted with one another
so it's in kind of a complex correlated
state of all those parts and when you
look at the parts one at a time it
doesn't tell you anything about the
state of the whole thing the whole
thing's in some definite state there's
information stored in it
you know you'd like to access that
information let me be a little more
concrete suppose it's a book okay okay
it's a book it's a hundred pages long so
if it's an ordinary book a hundred
people could each take a page and read
it they know what's on that page and
then they could get together and talk
and now they know everything that's in
the book right but if it's a quantum
book written in qubits where these pages
are very highly entangled there's still
a lot of information in the book but you
can't read it the way I just described
you can look at the pages one at a time
but a single page when you look at it
just gives you random gibberish it
doesn't reveal anything about the
content of the book why is that it's
there's information in the book but it's
not stored in the individual pages it's
encoded almost entirely and how those
pages are correlated with one another
that's what we mean by quantum
entanglement information stored in those
correlations which you can't see when
you look at the parts one at a time so
you asked about quantum error correction
yeah what's the basic idea it's to take
advantage of that property of
entanglement because let's say you have
a system of many particles mm-hmm and
the environment is kind of kicking them
around it's interacting with them
because you you can't really completely
turn off those interactions no matter
how hard you try but suppose we've
encoded the information in entanglement
so say if you look at one atom it's not
telling you anything about the
information you're trying to protect
yeah so the environment isn't learning
anything when it looks at the atoms one
at a time and this is kind of the key
thing that what makes quantum
information so fragile is that when you
look at it you disturb it this ordinary
water bottle
like that you know let's say we knew it
was either here or here and we didn't
know I would look at it I find out is
here I was ignorant of where it was to
start with now I know mm-hmm
but with a quantum system when you look
at it you you really change the state
there's no way to avoid that so if the
environment is looking at it in the
sense that information is leaking out to
the environment that's going to mess it
up so we have to encode the information
so the environment so to speak can't
find out anything about what the
information is and that's the idea of
quantum error correction if we encoded
an entanglement the environment is
looking at the parts one at a time but
it doesn't find out what the protected
information is yeah no so in other words
it's it's kind of measuring probability
the whole way along right I'm not sure
what you mean by that
so is it Grover's algorithm that was
bate like as a as quantum bits roll
through go through gates the probability
is determined of what what information
is being passed through what's being
computed yeah so Grover's algorithm is a
way of sort of doing an exhaustive
search through many possibilities okay I
know like let's say I'm trying to solve
some problem like you know a famous one
is the Traveling Salesman problem I have
told you what the distances are between
all the pairs of cities and now I want
to find the shortest route I can that
visits them all that's a really hard
problem and it's still hard for a
quantum computer but not quite as hard
because there's a way of solving it
which is to try all the different routes
and measure how long they are and then
find the one that's shortest and you
solved the problem the reason it's still
hard to solve is there's such a vast
number of possible routes what Grover's
algorithm does is it speeds up that
exhaustive search mm-hmm and in practice
it's not that big a deal what it means
is that you know if you have the same
processing speed you can handle about
you know twice as many say
before the problem becomes too hard to
solve as you could if you were using a
classical processor mm-hmm but as far as
what's quantum about grover it takes
advantage of the property in quantum
physics that probabilities might tell me
if I'm getting too inside Bassman Oh
perfect
that probabilities are the squares of
amplitudes this is interference and this
another part of the answer we can spend
the whole whole hour answering the
question what does quantum physics
another essential part of it is is what
we call interference and and this is
really crucial for understanding how
quantum computing works and that is that
probabilities add you know if you know
the probability of one alternative and
you know the probability of another then
you can add those together and find the
probability that one or the other
occurred mm-hmm and it's not like that
in quantum physics the famous example is
the double slit interference experiment
now I'm sending electrons let's say it
could be basketballs but it's an easier
experiment to do with electrons hmm at a
screen and they're two holes in the
screen and you can try to detect the
electron on the other side of the screen
mm-hmm and when you do that experiment
many times you can plot a graph showing
where the electron was detected you know
in each run or make a histogram of all
the different outcomes and the graph
Wiggles okay so if it were if you could
say there's some probability of going
through the first hole and some
probability of going through the second
and each time you've detected it it went
through either one or the other
there'd be no Wiggles in that graph
that's the interference that makes it
wiggle and the essence of the
interference is that nobody can tell
whether it went through the first slit
or the second slit the question is sort
of inadmissible and this interference
then occurs when we can add up these
different alternatives in a way which is
different from what we're used to it's
not right to say that the electron was
detected at this point because it had
some probability of going through the
first hole and some probability of going
through the second we add those
probabilities up that doesn't give the
right answer the different alternatives
can interfere mm-hmm and this is really
important for quantum computing because
what we're trying to do is enhance the
probability or the time it takes to find
the solution to a problem and this
interference can work to our advantage
we want to have you know when we're
doing our search we want to have a
higher chance of getting the right
answer and a lower chance of getting the
wrong answer and if the different wrong
answers can interfere they can cancel
one another out and that enhances the
probability of getting the right answer
so sorry it's such a long-winded no
answer but this is how Grover's
algorithm works so they can speed up
exhaustive search by taking advantage of
that interference phenomenon well this
it's kind of one of the underlying
questions among many of the questions
from Twitter you've you've hit our
record for most questions asked
but basically many many people are
wondering what quantum computers really
will do if and when it becomes a reality
that they outperform classical computers
what are they going to be really good at
well you know what I'm not really sure
and I think you know if you look at the
history of Technology it would be hubris
to expect me to know it's a whole
different way of dealing with
information there's quantum information
it's not just you know a quantum
computer is not just a faster way of
computing it deals with information in a
completely new way because of this
interference phenomenon because of
entanglement that we've talked about and
I think we have limited vision when it
comes to predicting decades out what the
impact will be of an entirely new way of
doing things information processing in
particular I mean you know this well if
we go back to the 1960s and people are
starting to put a few transistors on a
chip where is that going to lead nobody
knew even early days of the internet
even the hood exam even the first
browser hmm no one really knew what
anyone was going to do with it you know
it makes total sense for good or ill and
but we have some ideas you know I think
why are we confident there will be some
transformative effect on Society of the
things we know about and I emphasize
again probably the most important ones
are things we haven't thought of mmm
when it comes to applications of quantum
computing the ones which will affect
everyday life I think are better methods
for understanding and inventing new
materials new chemical compounds mm-hmm
things like that can be really important
you know if you find a better way of
capturing carbon by designing a better
catalyst or you can design
pharmaceuticals that have new effects
materials that have unusual properties
these are quantum physics problems
because those property
the molecule or the material really have
to do with the underlying quantum
behavior of the particles and we don't
have a good way for solving such
problems or predicting that behavior
using ordinary digital computers that's
what a quantum computer is good at it's
good but maybe not the only thing it's
good at but one thing it should
certainly be good at is telling us
quantitatively how quantum systems
behave and in the two contexts I just
mentioned there's little question that
there will be practical impact of that
so it's not it's not just doing the
Traveling Salesman problem through the
table of elements for like why it can
find those compounds it's much more than
if it were that would that wouldn't be
very efficient exactly yeah no it's much
trickier than that
and you know the like I said the
exhaustive search though conceptually
yeah it's really interesting that
quantum can speed it up because of
interference from a practical point of
view it may not be that big a deal it
means that well like I said in the same
amount of time you can solve an instance
which is twice as big of the problem so
what we rarely get excited about are the
so-called exponential speed ups and that
was why Shor's algorithm was excited
exciting in in 1994 because factoring
large numbers was a problem that had
been studied by smart people for a long
time and on that basis the fact that
there weren't any fast ways of solving
it was pretty good evidence it's a hard
problem actually we don't know how to
prove that from first principles maybe
somebody will come away you know come
along one day and figure out how to
solve factoring very fast on a digital
computer it doesn't seem very likely
because people have been trying ok for
so long
to solve problems like that and it's
just intractable with ordinary computers
you could say the same thing about these
quantum physics problems maybe some
brilliant graduate student is going to
drop a paper on the archive tomorrow
which will say here I solve quantum
chemistry and I can do it on a digital
computer but we don't think that's very
likely because we've been working pretty
hard on these problems for decades and
they seem to be really hard and so those
cases like these number theoretic
problems which have cryptological
implications and tasks for simulating
the behavior of quantum systems we're
pretty sure those are hard problems
classically and we're pretty sure
quantum computers when we have
algorithms that have been proposed but
which we can't really run currently
because our quantum computers aren't big
enough on the scale that's needed to
solve problems really people really care
about yeah so so maybe we should jump to
one of the questions from Twitter which
is related to that so Travis Shelton
asked what are the most problem
pressings in physics let's say
specifically around quantum computers
that you think substantial progress
ought to be made in to move the field
forward
I know Travis he was an undergrad oh
okay
are you doing Travis so the problems
that we need to solve to you know
quantum computing closer to realization
at the level that would solve problems
people care about well let's go over
where we are now yeah definitely okay so
people have been working on quantum
hardware for you know 20 years working
hard and there are a number of different
approaches to building hardware and
nobody really knows which is going to be
the best
we haven't we're I think we're far from
collapsing to one approach which
everybody agrees has the best long term
prospects for scalability
and so it's important that a lot of
different types of hardware are being
pursued and we can come back to what
some of the different approaches are
yeah later
but so where are we now we we think in a
couple of years we'll have devices with
about 50 cubits 200 and we'll be able to
control them pretty well and that's an
interesting range because even though
it's only 50 to 100 cubits doesn't sound
like that big a deal
but that's already too many to simulate
with a digital computer even with the
most powerful supercomputers today so
from that point of view oh you know
these are relatively small near-term
quantum computers which we'll be fooling
around with over the next five years or
so are doing something that's kind of
super classical yeah at least we don't
know how to do exactly the same things
with ordinary computers now that doesn't
mean they'll be able to do anything
that's practically important but we're
gonna try okay we're gonna try and there
are ideas about things we'll try out
including sort of baby versions of these
problems in chemistry and materials and
ways of speeding up optimization
problems nobody knows how well those
things are going to work at these small
scales part of the reason is not just
that the number of qubits is small but
they're also not perfect so we can
perform elementary operations on pairs
of qubits which we call quantum gates
like the gates and ordinary logic but
they have an error rate a little bit
below you know an error every hundred
gates so that if you have a circuit with
a thousand cubits there's a lot of noise
so exactly like it does for instance a
hundred qubit quantum computer really
mean a hundred quantum a hundred cubic
quantum computer or do you need a
certain amount of backup going on well I
think in the near term we're going to
be trying out and probably we have the
best hopes the kind of hybrid classical
methods with some kind of classical
feedback okay you try to do something on
the quantum computer you make a
measurement that gives you some
information then you change the way you
did it a little bit and try to converge
on some better answer and that's one
possible way of addressing optimization
that might be faster on a quantum
computer but I just wanted to emphasize
that the number of qubits isn't the only
yeah metro yeah and how good they are
and in particular the reliability of the
gates how well we can perform them
that's equally important so anyway
coming back to Travis's question well
there are lots of things yeah that we'd
like to be able to do better but just
having much better qubits would be huge
right so if you more or less with the
technology we have now you can have a
gate error rate of a few parts and a
thousand you know if you can improve
that by orders of magnitude then
obviously you could run bigger circuits
and that would be very enabling even if
you stick with a hundred qubits just by
having a circuit with more depth you
know more layers of gates that increases
the range of what you could do mm-hmm
so that's a and that's always going to
be important yes I mean look at that's
look at how crappy that is a gate error
rate even if it's one part in a thousand
it's pretty lousy compared to if you
look at where and yes processor a
billion transistors in it yeah and zero
and you don't you don't worry about the
it's gotten to the point where there is
some error protection built in at a
hardware level okay in a processor
because I mean we're doing these crazy
things like going down from 11 nanometer
scale for features on a chip so so how
are folks
trying to deal with interference right
now you mean what what types of devices
and you know so that's interesting too
because there are a range of different
ways to do it so I mentioned that we
could store information we can make a
qubit out of a single atom for example
that's one approach so you have to
control a whole bunch of atoms and get
them to interact with one another one
way of doing that is with what we call
trapped ions that means the atoms have
electrical charges that's a good thing
because then you can control them with
electric fields you can hold them in a
trap and you can isolate them like I
said in a very high vacuum so they're
not interacting too much with other
things in the laboratory including stray
electric and magnetic fields but that's
not enough because you got to get them
to talk to one another you got to get
them to interact I mean we have this set
of desiderata which are kind of in
tension with one another on the one hand
we want to isolate the qubits very well
yeah on the other hand we want to
control them from the outside and get
them to do what we wanted to do and
eventually we want to read them out you
have to be able to read out the result
of the computation but the key thing is
the control if you want to do two of
those qubits and your device to interact
with one another in a specified way and
do that very accurately you have to have
some kind of bus that gets the - to talk
to one another okay and the way they do
that in an ion trap is pretty
interesting it's by using lasers and
controlling how the ions vibrate in the
trap with a laser kind of excite Wiggles
of the ion and then by you know
determining whether the ions are
wiggling or not you can go address
another ion and that way you can do a
two qubit interaction and you can do
that pretty well okay another way is
really completely different what I just
described was encoding information at
the one yeah atom level
but another way is to use super
conductivity circuits in which electric
current flows without any dissipation
and in that case you have a lot of
freedom to sort of engineer the circuits
to behave in a quantum way there's there
are many nuances there but the key thing
is that you can encode information now
in a system that might involve the
collective motion of billions of
electrons and yet you can control it as
though it were a single atom I mean
here's one's oversimplified way of
thinking about it yeah suppose you have
a little loop of wire and there's
current flowing in the loop it's a
superconducting wire so it just keeps
flowing normally there'd be resistance
which would dissipate that as heat but
not for the superconducting circuit
which of course has to be kept very cold
to stay superconducting but you can
imagine in this little loop that the
current is either circulating clockwise
or counter clockwise so that's a way of
encoding information but it could also
be both at once and that's what makes it
a qubit right and so in that case I'll
even though it involves lots of
particles the magic is that you can
control that system extremely well I
mentioned individual electrons that's
another approach put the qubit and the
spin yeah of a single electron you also
mentioned better qubits what are you
doing by that what would I what I really
care about is how well I can do the
gates yeah and there's a whole other
approach which is motivated by the
desire to have much much better control
over the quantum information than we do
in those systems that I mentioned so far
like superconducting circuits and
trapped ions that's actually what
Microsoft is pushing very hard mm-hmm we
call it topological quantum computing
that's topological is so
word physicists and mathematicians love
it it means well let's we'll come back
to what it means just tell you what
they're trying to do they're trying to
make a much much better Cuba which they
can control much much better using a
completely different hardware approach
okay and it's very ambitious because at
this point it's not even clear they have
a single qubit but if that approach is
successful and we're it's making
progress so I think we will see a
validated qubit of this type soon maybe
next year okay and then I nobody really
knows where it goes from there but
suppose it's the case that you could do
a two qubit gate with an error rate of 1
million instead of one and a thousand
mm-hmm
I mean that would be that would be huge
now scaling all these technologies up
really challenging from a number of
perspectives including just the control
engineering but so it was so via how are
how are they doing it are attempting to
do it you know you could ask um where
did all this progress come from over 20
years or so for example with the
superconducting circuits a sort of
crucial measure is what we call the
coherence time of the qubit which
roughly speaking means how much it
interacts with the outside world the
longer the coherence time the better so
the rate of what we call decoherence is
essentially how much it's getting
buffeted around by outside influences
and for the superconducting circuits
those coherence times have increased
about a factor of 10 every 3 years going
back 15 years or so Wow
now it will necessarily go on like that
indefinitely but in order to achieve
that that type of progress better
materials better fabrication better
control the way you control these things
is with microwave
circuitry not that different from you
know the kind of things that are going
on and you know communication devices
and all those things are important but I
think going forward the control is is
really the critical thing coherence
times are already getting pretty long I
mean having them longer it's certainly
good but the key thing is to get to
qubits to interact just the way you want
them to and even if there is no I keep
saying the key thing is the environments
not the only key thing yeah because you
know you have some qubit like if we if
you think about that electron spin one
way of saying it is I said it can be
both up and down at the same time well
there's a simpler way of saying that it
might not point either up or down it
might point some other way but the early
a continuum ways of ways it could point
that's not like a bit you see it's much
easier to stabilize a bit because it's
got just two states yeah but if it can
kind of wander around in the space of
possible configurations for a qubit that
makes it much harder to control mm-hmm
and you know people have gotten better
at that a lot better at that in the last
few years
interesting so Joshua Herrmann asked
what engineering strategy for quantum
computers do you think has the most
promise yeah so I mentioned some of
these different approaches and I guess
I'll interpret the question as which one
is the winning horse yeah I know better
than to answer that question they're all
interesting okay but I for the near term
the most advanced are superconducting
circuits and trapped ions which is why I
mentioned those first and I think that
will remain true you know over the next
five to ten years there are other
technologies have the potential like
these topologically protected humans
to surpass those but it's not gonna
happen real soon I kind of like
superconducting circuits because there's
so much um
phase space of things you can do with
them you know of ways you can engineer
and configure them and imagine scaling
them up they have the advantage of being
faster than the time to take the cycle
time the time to do a gate is faster
than with the trapped ions just the
basic physics of the interactions is
different in the long term those
electron spins could catapult ahead of
these other things that's something that
you can naturally do in silicon and you
know it's potentially easy to enter gate
integrate with silicon technology right
now the you know qubits and gates aren't
as good as the other technologies but
that can change and I mean that from a
theorist perspective this topological
approach is very appealing and so we
could imagine you know it takes off
maybe ten years from now and it becomes
the leader so I think it's important to
emphasize we don't really know what's
going to scale the best right and are
there multiple attempts being made
around programming quantum computers
yeah I mean some of these companies yeah
that are working on quantum technology
now which includes well-known big
players like IBM and Google and
Microsoft and Intel but also a lot of
startups now they are trying to
encompass the full stack so they're
interested in the hardware and the
fabrication and the control technology
but also the software the applications
the user interface mm-hmm all those
things are certainly going to be
important eventually yeah they're
pushing it almost to like an AWS layer
where you you have you interact with
your quantum computer in a server farm
and you don't even touch it
yeah it seemed I think that that's how
it will be in the near term I think you
you're not going to have most of us
won't have a quantum computer you know
sitting on your desktop or in your
pocket maybe someday in the near term
it'll be on the cloud and you'll be able
to run applications on it by some kind
of web interface and you know ideally
that should be designed so the user
doesn't have to know anything about
going on physics in order to program or
use it and I think that's part of what
some of these companies are moving
toward do you do you think it will get
to the level where it's in your pocket
how do you deal with that when you
you're below 1 Kelvin well if it's in
your pocket it probably won't be 1
Kelvin oh yeah probably none so what do
you do well there's one approach as an
example which I guess I mentioned in
passing before or maybe it doesn't have
to be at such low temperature and that's
nuclear spins because they're very
weakly interacting with the outside
world you can have quantum information
in a nuclear spin which I mean ideal you
I'm not saying that it would be
undisturbed for years but seconds which
is pretty good okay um and you know you
can imagine that getting significantly
longer you know someday you might have a
little quantum smart card in your pocket
the nice thing about that particular
technologies you can do it at room
temperature still I'm long coherence
times and you know if you're if you go
to the ATM and you're worried that
there's a rogue Bank it's gonna steal
your information one solution to that
problem I'm not saying there aren't
other solutions is to have a quantum
card where the bank will be able to
authenticate it without being able to
forge it we should talk about the
security element
Kevin su asked what risk would quantum
computers pose to
current encryption schemes so public key
and what changes should people be
thinking about if quantum computers come
and that you know the next five years
ten years yeah
quantum computers threatened ecosystems
that are in widespread use whenever
you're using a web browser and you see
that little padlock and you're in a you
know HTTPS site you're using a public
key cryptosystem to protect your privacy
and those crypto systems rely for their
security on the presumed hardness of
computational problems that is it's
possible to crack them but it's just too
hard
so RSA which is one of the ones that's
widely used
mmm-hmm as typically practiced today the
to break it you'd have to do something
like factor a number which is over 2,000
bits long to 2048 and that's you know
that's too hard to do now mm-hmm but
that's what quantum computers will be
good at another one that's widely used
is called a elliptic curve cryptography
doesn't really matter exactly what it is
okay but the point is that it's also a
vulnerable to quantum attack yeah so
we're gonna have to protect our our
privacy in different ways when quantum
computers are prevalent what what are
the attempts being made right now well I
mean there are two main classes of
attempts okay
one is just to come up with a
cryptographic protocol not so different
conceptually from what's done now but
based on a problem that's hard for
quantum yeah and it turns out that what
has sort of become the standard way
doesn't have that feature and there are
alternatives that people are working on
how we speak of post quantum crypt
geography meaning the protocols that
we'll have to use when we're worried
that our adversaries have quantum
computers mm-hmm
and I don't think there's any proposed
crypto system although there's a long
list of them by now which people think
are candidates for being quantum
resistant for being unbreakable or hard
to break by quantum computers I don't
think there's anyone that you know the
world has sufficient confidence in now
that it's really hard for a quantum
adversary that we're all going to switch
over but it's certainly time to be
thinking about it you know when people
worry about the privacy of course
different users have different standards
but the US government sometimes says
they would like a system to stay secure
for 50 years they'd like to be able to
use it for 20 roughly speaking and then
have the intercepted traffic be
protected for another 30 after that so I
don't think though I could be wrong that
were likely to have quantum computers
that can break those public key
cryptosystems in ten years mm-hmm but in
50 years seems not unlikely and so we
should really be worrying about it and
the other one is actually using quantum
communication for privacy oh yeah so in
other words if you and I could send
qubits to one another instead of bits it
opens up new possibilities so the way to
think about these public key schemes are
one way that we're using now is I want
you to send me a private message and I
can send you a lock box or foot know it
has a padlock on it and but I keep the
key okay but you can close up the box
and send it to me mm-hmm
but I'm the only one with the key so the
key thing is that if you have the
padlock you can't reverse engineer the
key of course it's a digital box and key
you know that's the idea of public key
the idea of what we call quantum key
distribution which is a particular type
of quantum cryptography is that I can
actually send you the key or you can
send me your key but why can't any
eavesdropper then listen in and know the
key well it's because it's quantum and
remember it has that property that if
you look at it you disturb it so if you
collect information about my key or if
the adversary does that will cause some
change in the key and there are ways in
which we can check whether what you
received is really what I sent mm-hmm
and if it turns out it's not or it has
too many errors in it then we'll be
suspicious that there was an adversary
who tampered with it and then we won't
use that key because we haven't used it
yet we're just trying to establish the
key so we do the test to see whether an
adversary interfere if it passes the
test then we can use the key and if it
fails the test we throw that key away
and we try again that's how quantum
cryptography works but it requires a
much different infrastructure than what
we're using now we have to be able to
send qubits well it's not completely
different because you can do it with
photons and of course that's how we you
know communicate through optical fiber
now we're sending photons and it's a
little trickier sending quantum
information through an optical fiber
because of that issue that interactions
with the environment can disturb it but
nowadays you know you can send quantum
information through an optical fiber
over the tens of kilometers with you
know a low enough error rate so it's
useful for communication Wow of course
we'd like to be able to scale that up to
global distances sure and their big
challenge isn't that but anyway so
that's that's another approach to the
future of privacy that people are
interested in
and does that necessitate quantum
computers on both ends - yes but not
huge ones okay and the reason well yes
and no okay at the scale of tens of
kilometers no and that's you can do that
now there are prototype systems that are
in existence and but if you really want
to scale it up then in other words to
send things longer distance then you
have to bring this quantum error
correction idea into the game okay
because at least with you know our
current photonics technology there's no
way I can send a single photon from here
to China without there being a very high
probability that gets lost in the fibers
somewhere so we have to have what we
call quantum repeaters okay which can
boost the signal but it's not like the
usual type of repeater that we have in
communication networks now the usual
type is you measure the sync signal and
then you resend it okay I won't work for
quantum because as soon as you measure
it you're gonna mess it up so you have
to find a way of boosting it without
knowing what it is and of course it's
important that it works that way because
otherwise the adversary could just
intercept it and resend it and so it
will require some quantum processing to
get that quantum error correction in the
quantum repeater to work yeah but it's a
much more modest scale quantum processor
than we would need to solve hard
problems okay gotcha and what are the
other things that you're you're both
excited about and worried about for for
potential business opportunities Sneha I
mispronounce names all the time Sneha
and cat curry asks budding entrepreneurs
what should they be thinking about in
the context of quantum computing yeah I
mean there's more to quantum technology
than computing yeah and something which
has good potential
and to have an impact you know in the
relatively near future is improved
sensing hmm quantum systems it partly
because of that property that I keep
emphasizing that they can't be perfectly
isolated from the outside they're good
at sensing things and sometimes you know
you want to detect it there's something
in the outside world messes around with
your qubit yeah and again using this
technology of nuclear spins which I
mentioned you can do it at room
temperature potentially you can make a
pretty good sensor and it can
potentially achieve higher sensitivity
and spatial resolution and look on look
at things on shorter distance scales
than than other existing sensing
technology so one of the things people
are excited about are the biological and
medical implications of that if you can
monitor the behavior of molecular
machines you know probe biological
systems at the molecular level using
very powerful sensors and that would
surely have a lot of applications so one
interesting question you can ask is can
you know use these quantum error
correction ideas to make those sensors
even more powerful and that's another
area of you know current basic research
but where you could see you know
significant potential economic impact
interesting and so and so in terms of
your research right now what are you
working on that you find both
interesting and incredibly difficult
everything I will find is 100% Oersted
and incredibly difficult okay well let
me um change direction a little yeah
from what we've been talking about so
far well let me tell you a little bit
about me
sure so I
didn't start out interested in
information yeah a career you know I'm a
physicist and I was trained as no an
elementary particle theorist studying
the fundamental interactions and the
elementary particles and that drew me
into an interest in gravitation because
one thing that we still have a very poor
understanding of is how gravity fits
together with the other fundamental
interactions the way physicists usually
say it is we don't have a quantum theory
of gravity at least not one that we
think is complete and satisfactory so
I'm an interested in that question for
you know many decades and then I kind of
got sidetracked because I got excited
about quantum computing but you know I
I've always looked at quantum
information not just as a technology you
know I'm a physicist I'm not an engineer
I'm not trying to build a better
computer necessarily though I think
that's very exciting and worth doing and
if my work can contribute to that it's
very pleasing but I see quantum
information as a new frontier in the
exploration of the physical sciences
sometimes I call it the entanglement
frontier
you know we physics we like to talk
about frontiers short distance frontier
that's what we're doing at CERN you know
and the Large Hadron Collider trying to
discern new properties of matter at
distances which was shorter than we've
ever been able to explore before mm-hmm
and there's a long distance frontier in
cosmology you know we're trying to look
deeper into the universe and understand
its structure and behavior at earlier
times those are both very exciting
frontiers this entanglement frontier I
think is increasingly
going to be at the forefront of basic
physics research in the 21st century
mm-hmm and by entanglement frontier I
just mean scaling up quantum systems to
larger and larger complexity where it
becomes harder and harder to simulate
those systems you know with our existing
digital tools and so that means we can
very well anticipate the types of
behavior that we're going to see I think
that's a great opportunity for new
discovery and that's part of what's
going to be exciting even in the
relatively near term mmm-hmm
when we have a hundred qubits you know
there are some things that we can do to
understand the behavior of the dynamics
of you know a highly complex system of
100 qubits that we know have been able
to experimentally probe before and
that's going to be very interesting but
what we're starting to see now is that
these quantum information ideas are
connecting to these fundamental
questions about gravitation and how to
think about it quantum Li and it turns
out as is true for most of the broader
implications of quantum physics the key
thing is entanglement and we can think
of the microscopic structure of
space-time the geometry of where we live
geometry this means you know who's close
to who else and okay if we are we're in
the auditorium and you know I'm in the
first row and you're in the fourth row
you know the geometry is how close we
are to one another so of course that's
very fundamental in both space and time
how far apart are we in space how far
apart are we at a time is geometry
really a fundamental thing or is it
something that's kind of emergent from
some even more fundamental concept
it seems increasingly likely that it's
really an emergent B property okay
there's something deeper than geometry
what is that we think it's quantum
entanglement that you can think of the
geometry as arising from quantum
correlations among parts of a system and
that's really what defines who's close
to who and so we're trying to explore
that idea more deeply and one of the
things that comes in is the idea of
quantum error correction mm-hmm
remember the whole idea of quantum error
correction was that we could make a
quantum system behave the way we wanted
to because it's well-protected against
the damaging effects of noise and it
seems like quantum error correction is
part of the deep secret of how
space-time geometry works it has a kind
of intrinsic robustness coming from
these ideas of quantum error correction
that makes space you know meaningful so
that it doesn't just evaporate when you
when you tap on it if you wanted to you
know you could think of the space time
that the space the urine and the space
that that I'm in as parts of a system
that are entangled with one another
mm-hmm is what would happen if we broke
that entanglement and you know you're
part of space became disentangled from
my part Oh what we think that would mean
is that there'd be no way to connect us
anymore there wouldn't be any path
through space that starts over here with
you and ends with you would become
broken apart into two pieces so it's
really the entanglement which holds
space together which keeps it from
falling apart into little pieces and you
know we're trying to get a deeper grasp
of what that means and how do you make
any progress on that that seems like the
most unbelievably difficult problem to
work on it's difficult yeah as well for
a number of reasons but in particular
because it's hard to get guidance from
experiment which is how physics
historically all science has commenced
yeah and although it was fun
a moment ago to talk about what would
happen if we disentangled you're part of
space from mine I don't know how to do
that in the lab right now so of course
part of the reason is we have the
audacity to think we can figure these
things out just by thinking about them
maybe that's not true nobody knows right
we should try yeah under solving these
problems is a great challenge and you
know it may be that the Apes that
evolved on earth are not don't have the
capacity to understand things like the
quantum structure of space-time but
maybe we do so we should try now in the
longer term and maybe not such a long
term I think maybe we can get some
guidance from experiment and in
particular what we're gonna be doing
with quantum computers and you know the
other quantum technologies that are
becoming increasingly sophisticated in
the next couple of decades as we'll be
able to control very well highly
entangled complex quantum systems and so
that should mean that in a laboratory on
a tabletop I can sort of make my own
little toy spacetime hmm with an
emergent geometry arising from the
properties of that entanglement and I
think that'll teach us lessons because
systems like that are the type of system
that because they're so highly entangled
digital computers can't simulate them it
seems like only quantum computers are
potentially up to the task so that won't
be quite the same as you know
disentangling your side of the room for
mine in real life yeah but we'd be able
to do it in a laboratory setting you
know using model systems which i think
would help us to understand the basic
principles better wildd
yeah desktop space-time seems pretty
cool yeah it's pretty fundamental we
didn't really talk about what people
sometimes we didn't implicitly but not
in something we didn't talk about what
people sometimes call quantum
locality okay and it's another way of
describing quantum entanglement actually
there's this notion of Bell's Theorem
that when you look at the correlations
among the parts of a quantum system that
they're different from any possible
classical correlations and some things
that you read give you the impression
that you can use that to instantaneously
send information over long distances hmm
it is true that if we have two qubits
electron spin say and they're entangled
with one another then what's kind of
remarkable is that I can measure my
qubit to see along some axis whether
it's up or down and you can measure
yours and we will get perfectly
correlated results no what I when I see
up you'll see up say and when I see down
you'll see down and sometimes people
make it sound like that's remarkable
that's not remarkable in itself I could
have somebody could have flipped a pair
of coins you know so they came up both
heads and both tails and given one slip
them afire to me yeah and go on a light
you're opposed and then we do and then
they call it quantum transport a
teleportation on YouTube yeah
of course what's really important about
entanglement that makes it different
from just those coins yeah is that
there's more than one way of looking at
a qubit mm-hmm you know we have what we
call complementary ways of measuring it
sorry you know you can ask whether it's
up or down along this axis or along that
axis there's nothing like that for the
coin there's just one way to look at it
hmm and what's cool about entanglement
is it will get perfectly correlated
results if we both measure in the same
way mm-hmm but there's more than one
possible way that we can measure and so
what sometimes gets said or the
impression
Oh God is that that means that when I do
something to my cubit it instantaneously
affects your cubit even if we're on
different sides of the galaxy but that's
not what entanglement does it just means
they're correlated in a certain way
mm-hmm and when you look at yours if we
have maximally entangled qubits you you
just see a random Fett you know it could
be a zero or one each occurring with
probability 1/2 and that's going to be
true no matter what I did to my Cupid
and so you can't tell what I did by
looking at it it's only that if we
compare notes later we can see how
they're correlated and that correlation
holds for either one of these two
complementary ways in which we could
both measure and it's that fact that we
have these complementary ways to measure
that makes it impossible for a classical
system to reproduce those same
correlations mm-hmm
so that's one misconception that's
pretty widespread another one is this
about quantum computing which is in
trying to explain why quantum computers
are powerful people will sometimes say
well it's because you can superpose I
use that word before you know you can
add together many different
possibilities and that means that
whereas an ordinary computer would just
do a computation once acting on a
superposition and quantum computer can
do a vast number of computations all at
once there's a certain sense in which
that's mathematically true if you
interpret it right but it's very
misleading because in the end you're
gonna have to make some measurement to
read out the result mm-hmm and when you
read it out you're you know there's a
limited amount of information you can
get you're not going to be able to read
out the results of some huge number of
computations in a single shot
measurement so really the key thing that
makes it work is this idea of
interference which we discussed briefly
when you asked about Grover's algorithm
mm-hmm
the art of a quantum algorithm is to
make sure that the wrong answers
interfere and cancel one another out so
the right answer is enhanced and that's
not automatic it requires that the
quantum algorithm be designed in just
the right way right so the diagrams I've
seen online at least involve usually
you're like squaring the output as it
goes along and then like essentially
that that flips the the correct answer
to the positive and the others are in a
negative position is that accurate I
wouldn't have said it the way you did
okay because you can't really measure it
as you go along okay and once you
measure it the magic of superposition is
going to be lost mm-hmm it means that
now there's some definite outcome or
state so to take advantage of this
interference phenomenon you need to
delay the measurement mm-hmm remember
when we were talking about the double
slit and I said if you actually see
these these Wiggles in the probability
of detection which is the signal of
interference that means that there's no
way anybody could know whether the
electron went through hole 1 or hole 2
and it's the same way with quantum
computing if you think of the
computation as being a superposition of
different possible computations it
wouldn't work
there wouldn't be a speed-up if you
could know which of those paths the
computation followed it's important that
you don't know and so you have to sum up
all the different computations and
that's how the interference phenomenon
comes into play to take a little
sidetrack you mentioned Fineman before
and before we started recording you
mentioned working with him I know I'm in
the the Fineman fan club for sure yeah
what was that experience like we never
really collaborated I mean we didn't
write a paper together or anything
that but we overlap for five years at
Caltech yeah arrived here in 1983 he
died in 1988 we in offices on the same
corridor and we talked pretty often
because we were both interested in the
fundamental interactions and in
particular what we call quantum
chromodynamics it's our theory of how
nuclear matter behaves how quarks
interact what holds the proton together
those kinds of things and one big
question is you know what does hold the
proton together why don't the quarks
just fall apart so that was an example
of a problem that both he and I were
very interested in and which we talked
about some time now you know this was
pretty late in his career actually sure
when I when I think about it now when I
arrived at Caltech that was 1983 Fineman
was born in 1918 so he was 65
I'm 64 now so maybe he wasn't so old but
at the time he seemed pretty ancient to
me yeah since I was thirty okay and
those who interacted with dick Feynman
you know when he was really at his
intellectual peak in the 40s and 50s and
60s probably saw even more extraordinary
intellectual feats and I witnessed
interacting with the 65 world Fineman
but he just loved physics you know and
he just thought everything was so much
fun and he left talking about it he
wasn't as good a listener as a talker
but actually well that's a little unfair
isn't it okay it was kind of funny
because Fineman um he won't always wants
to think things through for himself okay
you know
from first principles rather than rely
on the guidance from experts who have
thought about these things before well
that's fine you know you yeah you should
try to understand things as deeply as
you can on your own and sort of
reconstruct the knowledge from the
ground up that's very enabling and you
know gives you new insights but he was a
little too dismissive in my view of you
know what the other guys knew but I
could slip it in because you know I
didn't tell him
dick you should read this paper by
Polyakov well maybe I did I wouldn't
even heard that because he saw that
problem that your yang about yeah but I
knew what poly coffin said about it so I
would say oh well you know why don't we
look at it this way and so he thought I
was you know what I was having all these
insights but the truth was the venom a
difference between phiman and me and in
the mid-1980s is I was reading
literature and he wasn't and probably if
he had been it would have he would have
been well served but that wasn't the way
he liked to work on things yeah he
wanted to find his own approach and of
course that had worked out pretty well
for him throughout his career what other
qualities did you notice about him when
he was you know roaming the corridors
well he's drumming I don't even know he
was around because he'd actually be
walking down the hallway drumming on the
wall with his hands are with sticks her
no hands okay I'll just be tapping the
bongo thing yeah and so that was one
thing okay uh-huh
he loved to tell stories you know you
probably read the the books that the
Ralph Layton put together based on the
stories Fineman told and I mean I Ralph
did an amazing job I think of of
capturing fineman's personality in in
writing those stories down because I had
heard a lot of them okay I'm sure he
told the same stories too many
people many times because he left
telling stories and but the book really
captures his voice pretty well mm-hmm
you know if you had heard him tell some
of these stories and then and then you
read the way the way Ralph Leighton not
transcribed them you can write you can
hear Fineman talking and so at the time
that I knew him one of the experiences
that he went through was you know he was
on the Challenger Commission after the
Space Shuttle blew up and so he was in
in Washington a lot of the time but he
had come back from time to time and he
would sort of you know sit back and
relax in our seminar room and start
bringing us up to date on all the weird
things that were happening on the
Challenger Commission that was pretty
fun that's right cool a lot of that got
got captured in the second volume I
guess it's the one called um what do you
care what other people think there's a
there's a chapter about you know him
telling stories about the Challenger
Commission he was interested in
everything you know wasn't just physics
yeah and he's very interested in biology
he was interested in computation I
remember how excited he was when he got
his first IBM PC probably not long after
I got to Caltech yeah it was what they
called the 80 we thought it was pretty
sexy machine I had one too and you know
he couldn't wait to start programming it
and basic cool that was so much fun
there was a question that I was kind of
curious to your answer so teeka asked
about essentially teaching about quantum
computers so they say many kids in grade
10 can code some can play with machine
learning tools without knowing the math
can quantum computing become as simple
and or accessible
maybe so so at some level you know when
people say the quantum mechanics is
counterintuitive it's hard for us to
grasp it's so foreign to our experience
that's true the way things behave at the
microscopic scale or when you discussed
earlier we're really different from the
way ordinary stuff behaves but I think
it's a question of familiarity and what
I wouldn't be surprised by is that if
you go out a few decades kids who are 10
years old are going to be playing
quantum games hmm that's a application
area that just good discussed very much
but there could be a real market there
because you know people love games
yeah and quantum games are different and
the strategies are different and what
you have to do to win is different and
if you just play the game enough you
start to get the hang of it soon and so
I think I don't see any reason why kids
who have not necessarily deeply studied
physics can't get a pretty good feel for
how quantum mechanics works you know the
way um the way ordinary physics works
maybe it's not so intuitive Newton's
laws you know
Aristotle couldn't get it right right he
had to keep pushing on something to get
it to keep moving that wasn't right and
you had to you know Galileo was able to
roll balls down a ramp and things like
that and you see he didn't have to keep
pushing keep it moving and you could see
that it you know was uniformly
accelerated in a gravitational field
Newton took that to a much more general
and powerful level and you know you fool
around with stuff and you get the hang
of it and I think one of the stuff can
be like that it's you know we'll
experience it in a different way but
when we have quantum computers in a way
you know that opens the opportunity to
for trying things out and see what
happens
mm-hmm and after you played the game
enough you you start to anticipate
actually it's an important point about
the applications yeah one of the
questions you asked near the beginning
was um what are we able to do with
quantum computers and I said I don't
know so how are we going to discover new
applications am I just in least in part
be fooling around yeah you know a lot of
classical algorithms that that people
use on today's computers were discovered
or that they were powerful was
discovered by experimenting by trying it
I don't know what's an example of that
well the simplex method you know that we
use some linear programming I don't
think there was a mathematical proof
that it was fast at first but people did
experiments and they said hey this is
pretty fast you see you're seeing it a
lot now in machine learning yeah you you
test it out a million times over when
you're running simulations and it turns
out that that's what works yeah what
about so kind of like following the
threat of Education and and maybe your
political interest given its yeah the
year that it is do you have thoughts on
how you would adjust or change STEM
education
well no particularly original thoughts
okay
but I do think that STEM education we
shouldn't think of it as we're going to
need this technical workforce and so we
better train them I think the key thing
is we want the general population to be
able to reason effectively you know and
to recognize when an argument is phony
and when it's authentic and to think
about well how can I check whether what
I just read on Facebook is really true
and I see that as part of the goal of
STEM education you know when you're
teaching kids in school how to
understand the world by doing
experiments by looking at the evidence
by reasoning from the evidence this is
something that we apply in everyday life
too and so I would like to I don't know
exactly how to implement this yeah but I
think we should have that perspective
that we're trying to educate a public
which is going to eventually make
critical decisions about our democracy
and they should understand what's how to
tell when something is true or not I
mean you know that's a hard thing to do
in general but you know what I mean yeah
that there are some things that if
you're a person with some it doesn't
necessarily have to be technical but if
you're used to evaluating evidence and
making a judgement based on that
eminence about whether it's a good
argument or not you can apply that to
all the things you hear and read and
make better judgments what about on the
policy side someone let's see JJ Francis
passed that if you or any of your
colleagues would ever consider running
for office mm-hmm
curious about sign science policy in the
US well it would be good if we had more
scientifically trained people mm-hmm in
government
very few members of Congress I know one
bill fosters a physicists in Illinois he
was a particle physicists um and he
worked at Fermilab and hmm now he's in
Congress and I think very interested in
you know the science and educational
policy aspects of government rush Holt
was a congressman from New Jersey who
had a background in physics he retired
from the house a couple of years ago but
he was in Congress for something like 18
years and I think he had a a positive
influence because he had a voice that
people respected when it came to science
policy and having more people like that
would help now another thing it doesn't
have to be elective office right and we
and there are a lot of technically
trained people mm-hmm in government many
of them making their careers in agencies
that deal with you know technical issues
mm-hmm Department of Defense of course
there are a lot of technical issues in
the Obama administration we had two
successive secretaries of Energy who
were very very good physicists Steve she
was a Nobel Prize winning physicist and
then Ernie Moniz so real authority on
nuclear energy and weapons and that kind
of expertise makes a difference in
government hmm now the Secretary of
Energy is Rick Perry it's a different
background yes you could say that it
just kind of historical reference what
policies did they put in place that you
think were that you really felt their
hand as a physicist yeah move forward
you mean in particular during the Obama
administration yeah well I think the
Department of Energy do II tried to
facilitate
technical innovation by you know seating
new technologies by supporting startup
companies that were trying to do things
that would improve battery battery
technology and solar power and things
like that which could benefit future
generations and I think um I think they
had an impact by doing that oh you don't
have to be a Nobel Prize winning
physicist to think that's a good idea
but I think um you know that they that
the administration felt that was a
priority yeah I made a difference and
appointing a physicist Department of
Energy was if nothing else highly
symbolic of how important those things
are and on the on the quantum side
someone asks Vika scrod he asked where
the quantum Valley might be do you have
your thoughts as in Silicon Valley for
quantum computing well I don't know but
you look at what's happening the last
couple of years there have been a number
of quantum startups mm-hmm and a notable
number of them are in the Bay Area
why so well that's where the tech
industry is concentrated and where the
people who are interested in financing
innovative technical startups are
concentrated mm-hmm so if you are an
entrepreneur interested in starting a
company and you're concerned about how
to fundraise for it kind of makes sense
to locate it in that area that's not
that's what's sort of happening now and
may continue of course and might not be
like that indefinitely nothing lasts
forever but I would say that's the place
there's the Silicon Valley is like in
quantum Valley the way things are right
now well then what about the
the physicists who might be listening to
this if they're thinking about starting
a company mmm do you have advice for
them just speaking very generally that
if you're putting a team together mm-hmm
you know different people have different
expertise will take quantum computing as
an example you know like we were saying
earlier some of the big players and the
startups they want to do everything they
want to build the hardware figure out
better ways to fabricate it better
control better software better
applications nobody can be an expert on
all those things so you know of course
you'll hire a software person to write
your software and a microwave engineer
to figure out your control and of course
that's the right thing to do but I think
in in that arena and it probably applies
to other entrepreneurial activity
relating to physics being able to
communicate across those boundaries it's
very valuable and you can see it in
quantum computing now that if the man or
woman who's involved in the software
mm-hmm has that background but there's
not a big communication barrier talking
to the people who are doing the control
engineering yeah that can be very
helpful and I think so so I think it
makes sense to give some preference to
the people who maybe are comfortable
doing so or half the background this
stretches across more than one of those
areas of expertise I think I think that
can be very enabling in a technology
arena like quantum computing today where
we're trying to do really really hard
stuff and you know you don't know
whether you'll succeed and you want to
give it your best go by seeing the
actions you know between those different
things would you advise someone then to
to maybe teach or you know try and
explain it to I don't know they're young
cousins because I I think like Fineman
may be recognized as the king of
communicating physics at least for a
certain period of time mhm
how would you advise someone to get
better at it so they can be more
effective practice well you know their
different aspects of that this isn't
what you meant at all but I'll say it
anyway because what you asked brought it
to mind if you teach you learn and we
had this odd model in the research
university that a professor like me
is supposed to do research and teach
mm-hmm why don't I just when we hire
teachers and researchers why do you at
the same people doing both well part of
the reason for me is most of what I know
or what I've learned since my own school
education and it is knowledge I acquired
by trying to teach it hmm
and you know to keep our intellect
rejuvenated and we have to have that
experience of trying to teach new things
that we didn't know that well before to
other people that deepens your knowledge
just thinking about how you convey it
makes you ask questions that you might
not think to ask otherwise and you say
hey I don't know the answer to that and
then you have to try to figure it out so
I think that applies you know at varying
levels to any situation in which a
scientist or somebody with a technical
background mm-hmm is trying to
communicate by thinking about how to get
it across to other people we can get new
insights you know we can look at it in a
different way hmm um and so it's not a
waste determinant aside from the
benefits of actually successfully
communicating
yeah it we benefit from it in this other
way but other than that um have fun with
it
you know um don't look at it as as a
burden or you know some kind of task you
have to do along with all the other
things you're doing it should be a
pleasure and when it's successful it's
very gratifying so if you put a lot of
thought into how to communicate
something and you think people are
getting it that's one of the ways that
somebody in my line of work can get a
lot of satisfaction hmm if now we're to
be your opportunity to teach a lot of
people about physics and you could just
point someone to things who would you
advise someone to be they want to learn
more about quantum computing they want
to learn about physics what should they
be reading what YouTube channels should
they follow what should they pay
attention to well one communicator who I
have great admiration for is Leonard
Susskind I kind of said Stanford you
know you mentioned Fineman as the great
communicator and that's fair but in
terms of style and personality of
physicists who are currently active I
think Lenny Susskind is the most similar
to Fineman of anyone I can think of he
you know he's a no-bullshit kind of guy
yeah he he wants to give you the
straight stuff he doesn't want to water
it down for you but he's very gifted and
when it comes to you know making
analogies and creating the illusion that
you're understanding what he's saying so
he has if you just go to youtube and
search Leonard Susskind you'll see
lectures that he's given hmm at Stanford
where they have some kind of extension
school you know for people who are not
Stanford students people in the
community
yeah a lot of them in the tech community
because at Stanford and he's giving
courses and yeah and on on quite
sophisticated topics um but also on more
basic topics and he's in the process of
turning those into books I'm not sure
how many of those have appeared but he
has a series called I think the
theoretical minimum okay which is
supposed to be the you know the gentle
introduction to different topics like
classical physics and quantum physics
and so on mm-hmm
so he's he's pretty special I think in
his ability to do that mm-hmm I need to
subscribe actually here's a question man
in in the things you've relearned
while teaching over the past I guess
it's over 35 years
no [ __ ] is that right something like
that true
well what were the big thing what were
the revelations well that's how I
learned quantum computing for one thing
you know I was not at all knowledgeable
about information science that wasn't my
training and back when I was in school
physicists didn't learn much about
things like information they're computer
science complexity theory and one of the
great things that about quantum
computing is its interdisciplinary
character mm-hmm that it brings these
different things into contact which
traditionally had not been part of the
common curriculum of any community of
scholars and so I decided 20 years ago
that I should teach a quantum
information class at at Caltech and I
worked very hard on it that year and
that meant I I mean not that I'm an
expert or anything but I learned a lot
about information theory and things like
you know channel capacity and
computational complexity and you know
how we classify the hardness of problems
and algorithms things like that which I
didn't really know very well I had sort
of a passing familiarity with some of
those things from reading some of the
you know quantum computing literature
but that's no substitute for teaching in
class because and then you imporantly
have to synthesize it and figure out
your way of presenting it and most of
the notes are you know typed up and you
can still get to them on my website
mm-hmm but that was pretty
transformative for me because although
it didn't and and it was easier than 20
years ago I guess then it is now because
it was such a new topic yeah but I
really felt I was kind of you know close
enough to the cutting edge okay on most
of those topics by the time I had
finished the glass that I you know
wasn't intimidated by another paper I'd
read or a new thing I'd hear about about
those things so that was probably the
one case where it really made a
difference and you know my foundation of
knowledge which enabled me to do things
but I had the same experience in
particle physics you know I when I was a
student I read a lot and I was you know
very broadly interested in physics and
but when the first time I was still at
Harvard at the time but I didn't and I
taught a similar course here I'm in my
late 20s I'm just a year or two out of
graduate school and I decide to teach a
very comprehensive class on elementary
particles and in particular you know
quantum chromodynamics the theory of
nuclear forces like we talked about
before and it just really expanded my
knowledge to had that experience of
teaching that class and you know a lot
of I still draw on that you know I
noticed I can still
remember that experience and I think I
get ideas that I might not otherwise
have because I went through that I want
to get involved now yeah I want to go
back to school or maybe teach a class I
don't know well what's stopping you
nothing all right thanks John okay thank
you
you